hallo klickum hallo Farid Bang Farid
meine Frage an dich wäre jetzt der
Haftbefehl einong mit zo gemacht hat
bist jetzt sauer auf ihn hast jetzt Beef
mit ihm oder so oder interessiert dich
das alles gar nicht ich würde mich über
eine Antwort freuen Ciao auf keinen Fall
habe ich Beef mit Haftbefehl haftbefehl
ist mein Bruder schönen Gruß auch nach
Offenbach und wenn wir schon in
Offenbach sind grüße ich auch meinen
guten Freund asi Toni äh auch mein mein
Idol und ich habe auf jeden Fall ich
habe kein Beef mit Haftbefehl es ist
nach wie vor alles gut wenn ich
sind wir jetzt noch bessere Homies und
äh er hat doch ich kann es vollkommen
nachvollziehen auch wenn ich sido für
ein Waschlappen halte heißt es ja nicht
dass der irgendwie
nicht bekannt ist oder berühmt ist einer
der erfolgreichsten Rapper in
Deutschland und deswegen äh ist auf
jeden Fall eine gute Sache für
Haftbefehl und ist new Kammer und freut
mich auch dass ihn große Leute
bestätigen die sage ich mal musikalisch
was geschafft haben auch
wenn ich sie du nach wie vor von seiner
Musik und vom Typen her finden lutsch
alte